Artists like to share stories about sparks
of inspiration that motivate them to create.
When it comes to HBO's new adaptation of His
Dark Materials, that spark happens to be one
very distressing flight.
In an interview with The Los Angeles Times,
His Dark Materials executive producer Jane
Tranter revealed that a terrifying experience
while flying was behind her push to bring
Philip Pullman's popular fantasy novel series
to the small screen.
The incident happened around five years ago
while Tranter was on a flight from Los Angeles
to New York.
During the flight, a silence fell over the
passengers as the plane began to quickly lose
altitude.
As Tranter tells it, the pilots jumped into
action and prepared to make an emergency landing
in Chicago.
Tranter became emotionally overwhelmed, too
afraid to finish the work she was doing.
So she turned to her Kindle instead.
To comfort herself, Tranter began reading
the end of Pullman's The Amber Spyglass, the
final book in the author's best-selling His
Dark Materials trilogy.
Tranter told the LA Times:
"The books are so spiritual, and they have
got so much to say about our human mortality
and what death means and separation.
It took me to another world."
The experience convinced Tranter to follow
up on the rights of Pullman's books, a curiosity
that led her straight into the offices of
New Line Cinema.
The studio had already attempted to adapt
the books to film in 2007, but ultimately
dropped those plans after the first installment,
The Golden Compass, underperformed both critically
and at the box office.
The Twilight Saga: New Moon director Chris
Weitz helmed and wrote that particular Pullman
adaptation, which cost the studio $180 million
to make but only earned around $70 million
domestically, with most of its box office
takings coming from overseas.
The Golden Compass also faced hurdles beyond
its inability to draw a crowd.
For example, Pullman's books were fiercely
critical of both the Catholic Church and Christianity
in general.
"Philip Pullman is a known atheist.
He's been known to be pushing on kids for
a long time.
He put out a DVD, for example, in England,
that says, 'Why atheist?'"
As a result, they became the subject of intense
debate and scrutiny by some religious audiences,
and the 2007 movie was no different.
The story was so controversial that, in the
year after the film's shaky release, The Golden
Compass landed in the American Library Association's
list of top 10 books that individuals and
organizations had attempted to have banned
in the United States.
New Line attempted to curb some of this reaction
to the film by watering down the film's religious
content, but other critics and audiences seemed
to think that decision hurt more than it helped
the narrative.
Despite a less-than-stellar box office turnout
and the controversy surrounding the original
movie, Tranter convinced studio executives
that Pullman's fantasy could live again on
the small screen.
She and the rest of the His Dark Materials
team were able to persuade not only New Line
executives that the television adaptation
was worth the risk, but also several high-profile
stars including James McAvoy, Ruth Wilson,
and Lin-Manuel Miranda.
It's a win Tranter attributed to another popular
HBO adaptation, which helped make the case
that an elaborate fantasy like Pullman's could
both be done and be well-received.
Tranter explained:
"Game of Thrones really did that job for me."
Not many movies that struggle at the box office
get a second chance on the small screen, and
Tranter took a risk with His Dark Materials
but it seems that her leap of faith has paid
off in kind, as response to the small-screen
adaptation has been stellar so far.
Holding an 84 percent critical rating and
a 92 percent audience score on Rotten Tomatoes,
His Dark Materials is being praised for its
impressive performances, strong visuals and
its ability to capture the spirit of Pullman's
original novels.
One critic even wrote that the show is:
"...proof that TV is now the best medium for
bringing epic literary fantasy to the screen."
Almost makes that death-defying flight worth
it, don't you think?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.